as you have noticed especially if you
listen to this show there's been a lot
of attention recently on left-wing
indoctrination in schools and abuses of
power by left-wing administrators the
corporate media has ignored these issues
as much as it possibly can most outlets
have totally refused to report on the
developments in loudoun county
most of them have just said nothing at
all about it the washington post did
mention the case in an article yesterday
but the article doesn't say that the
assault happened in a bathroom doesn't
mention anything about the bathroom
policies loudoun county pushed through
it doesn't mention that the alleged
rapist was reportedly wearing a skirt it
doesn't say anything about scott smith
the father who was framed as a domestic
terrorist because he got upset that his
daughter was assaulted in other words
the washington post reported on the
story
without actually reporting on the story
and even that was far more than what
most corporate media outlets have been
willing to do
still ignore it as much as they want
leftist indoctrination and corruption in
schools has become a major issue people
are clued in
they are awakened to the problem
and that's why the media's next strategy
since the blackout strategy hasn't
worked i mean that's always their first
go-to if if there's a story they don't
want to talk about
the most obvious thing is well we're not
going to talk about it
if that doesn't work then they need to
get a little bit more desperate and
that's when you get to the classic
diversion tactic
and that's why if you were to check cnn
or nbc news or the huffington post or
aoc's twitter feed yesterday or this
morning
you would have seen huge screaming
headlines
telling us uh about this story from from
this is from the nbc story that aoc
shared it says
a school administrator in texas advised
teachers last week that if they have a
book about the holocaust in their
classroom they should also have a book
with an opposing perspective
now aoc when she was sharing this adds
this concept this comment she says
there's a reason white supremacy attacks
history opposition to teaching bigotry's
history and where it leads from the
slave trade to the holocaust is about
erasing society's tools to recognize
prejudice and prevent atrocity
holocaust denial has no place in our
society none
now this has been treated as a major
story
a teacher in a school district in texas
secretly recorded a meeting with a woman
named gina petty who's the district's
executive director of curriculum and
instruction
in the meeting petty is telling the
teachers about the new texas law hb 3979
which effectively bans critical race
theory
and that bill does a lot more than that
and we'll get to the bill in a minute
and what it actually does
but petty is explaining to the teachers
what this bill requires and its
implications
petty it's clear from the audio
doesn't like the bill
she also doesn't understand the bill
or at least isn't telling the truth
about it whether intentionally or not
and so the school administrator in the
context of explaining a texas bill that
she doesn't like and is misconstrued
makes this claim to the teachers about
the holocaust let's um let's listen to
the audio now
we are in the middle of a political mess
and you are in the middle of a political
mess
and so we just have to do the best that
we can
and
so we're going to go and we're going to
do you're going to do what you do best
and that's to teach kids i think we're
all just really terrified i think you
are terrified and i wish i could take
that away
i do
i can't
i can't do that you are professionals
we hired you
as professionals we trust you with our
children
so
if you think the book is okay
then let's go with it
and whatever happens we will fight it
together we will there's a lot of
districts that are in the exact same
spot we're in
and no one knows how to navigate these
waters i mean no one as you go through
just try to remember the concepts of
39.79 and make sure that if
if you have a book on the holocaust that
you have one that has a posing
that has others how do you oppose the
holocaust
believe me that's come up so number the
start
if you have a book on the holocaust make
sure you have a book that has the
opposing perspective that's that's what
uh the the petty there says now an
important point
the texas bill absolutely does not
require that schools give opposing
perspectives on the holocaust that's not
what the bill does that's total nonsense
the story here is that is that texas
passed a law
banning the political and racial
indoctrination of children in schools
which would include an effective ban on
critical race theory though that's not
the sole focus of the legislation
a school administrator doesn't like the
bill and caricatured it to her teachers
thereby misinforming them about what is
actually required of them
that's the story if it's a story at all
but that's not what the media wants us
to take from this
they want us to believe that the
administrator's interpretation is
correct this bill that this bill banning
critical race theory actually prevents
teachers from talking about the evils of
racism at all in fact the huffington
post headline about this bill when it
was passed back in june said exactly
that their headline was texas governor
signs law to stop teachers from talking
about racism
now if that was what the bill
accomplished then yeah i suppose you'd
have to talk about the holocaust
objectively quote unquote and give two
sides to the issue of whether or not
jews should be exterminated
but that's not what the bill says
here's what it says i'll read it i'll
read the relevant portion to you this is
what it
says quote for any social studies course
in the required curriculum a teacher may
not be compelled to discuss a particular
event or widely debated and currently
controversial issue of public policy or
social affairs
a teacher who chooses to discuss such a
topic shall to the best of the teacher's
ability strive to explore the topic from
diverse and contending perspectives
without giving deference to anyone to
any one perspective
okay so this is about widely debated
current events
is the holocaust a widely debated
current event no
the point in this legislation is that if
a teacher is going to talk about some
kind of controversial current event say
vaccine mandates or gun control or
whatever they should encourage the
students to look at it from different
perspectives and they shouldn't force
their perspectives on their students
that's all
the media has decided that if teachers
can't impose their political views on
students then that means somehow they
can't even say the holocaust was bad
this is what we call a reductio ad
absurdum argument taking an entirely
reasonable idea like teachers shouldn't
bring their political biases into the
classroom and we're reducing it to an
absurdity by claiming that this would
somehow entail holocaust denial
as for the claim that the texas bill
stops teachers from talking about racism
i mean that's not a reduction to the
absurd so much as just a flat out lie in
fact the bill specifically instructs
schools to teach students about a range
of historical subjects
and subjects related to civics including
this from the legislation this is what
it says
as something that they're supposed to
teach quote the history of white
supremacy including but not limited to
the institution of slavery the eugenics
movement and the kkk and the ways in
which it is morally wrong
that's in the bill
so
while the media democrats say that the
bill bans teachers from talking about
racism it actually instructs them to
talk about it
right there in plain language
in fact in in that uh huffington post
article that says teachers are banned
from talking about racism
they do include the bill itself that you
can read and you just read the bill and
it says the opposite of the headline
not only that but it bans the practice
of racism in the classroom
so you talk about racism but you can't
actually be racist in the classroom as a
teacher
that's what the bill says again from the
legislation it says the teachers shall
not quote
be required to engage in training
orientation or therapy
that presents any form of race or sex
stereotyping or blame on the basis of
race or sex or require or make part of a
course the concept that one race or sex
is inherently superior or that an
individual by virtue of the individual's
race or sex is inherently racist sexist
or oppressive
that's again in the bill this this is
not a prohibition
of the discussion of racism in the
classroom
it's a prohibition of racism itself in
the classroom
a teacher could talk about racism
but it can't actually be racist or teach
racist concepts
so the reality is always is exactly the
opposite of what the media presents
and this is their real problem with the
bill by the way
the kind of racism just described
casting blame and guilt on the basis of
race
um that's exactly what the media and
democrats want in the classroom
that's what alexandria caser cortez
wants in the classroom
and everywhere else in society
and no matter what else whatever else
they say or claim that's the real
problem
if you enjoyed this video be sure to
give it a thumbs up and share it with
all your friends